[Music]
um
the uk is about to introduce a
cyber flashing law that makes sending
unsolicited photos of genitals a
crime wow like what happens on omegle
and stuff when you're on those random
chats
unsolicited dick pics yeah you know like
chat roulette oh you don't know who
you're gonna talk to and then it just
randomly turns on it's just a guy's dick
or when you're on that airplane
everybody's air drop that's on the plane
you just drop your dick pic
have you ever done that no what a
blessing those people got them
you know what i like to do when i'm at
concerts and i see people recording the
concert and i think that's annoying i
just air drop them hell of [ __ ] and it
cancels their recordings
i also think that's annoying they don't
know it's you and they go oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he doesn't go to watch concerts he just
[ __ ] the kids
next time you're at a concert and the
guy in front of you [ __ ] holding it
up like this just air drop them hella
[ __ ] right in front of your face and
then they just go with the flesh if
they're like blocking exactly the view
yeah dude just air drop that [ __ ] that's
really good easy antidote
concert did you do that at i gabby had a
scholar
you know what that is now no i don't i'm
lost on that one was just an influencer
homie
so cyber flashers
could face jail time under revised
sexual assault legislation in the uk uh
in england and wales there's currently
no specific offense against cyber
flashing while indecent exposure can see
people forced to sign the sex offenders
register and serve a maximum of two
years in prison
in scotland it's an offense to cause a
person to look at a sexual image without
their consent and the crime was added to
its sexual offenses act more than a
decade ago
cyber flashing is the sending of
unsolicited obscene images to strangers
over any form of online messaging
whether it be whatsapp or facebook or
transferring them to another person's
phone using bluetooth services like
airdrop on iphones i like that it's cool
the latter has become increasingly
common especially for women on public
transport
how do they catch them
see that's how like it's like if you get
a dick pic you're like ah [ __ ] man and
then you look at their camera some
[ __ ] troll with a fake like anime
dude or whatever
and you're like how do you even trace
this [ __ ] and see who the [ __ ] did this
to you they i doubt they can that's true
huh so how do you even like know it's
their dick
it doesn't have to be right it just has
to be a dick yeah a dick yeah because
they could or genitals sorry we got to
be inclusive here just genitals all
kinds of drinks yeah because girls are
sending their vagina pics to everyone
what if it's like a [ __ ] vitruvian
man or like a leonardo da vinci painting
yeah yeah i think that's art i think
that's classified as the difference but
if you zoom just into the dick of the
leonardo da vinci vitruvian man it's a
dick that's a dick pic what about belly
what about belly button region belly
button to kneecap i think there's got to
be like a percentage ratio of the body
for it to still be like anatomy there
has to be face in it
at least yeah at least yeah identifiable
face so you know with the dick yeah with
the dick this seems like a crime that's
only like punishable if the guy admits
it was him really airdrop will say your
name usually i bet you could find him oh
yeah right but then like you'd have to
stay around for the cops to get there
and be like i am steve i did it i'm
sleeping but if you just [ __ ] run
like that's it you're gone out of the
situation do you think the guys that are
sending dick pics on public
transportation are thinking that forward
though nah
or do you think they're getting the same
the same adrenaline rush as like a a um
that's like kind of has to like kind of
wait there and bait like a modern day
trench coat flasher i think so
cause it's on the bus and he sends me
his dick and it's like did i see the
picture from nick except i could
screenshot that right and now we're on
the bus still for like another 20
minutes now i can notify the authorities
you gotta stop the bus and check
everyone's
penis literally says it's from you but
how do you know who's who's that person
like they'd have to say that's my name
that's true because it's not next to the
picture right if they really wanted to
they could probably look up like the
metadata yeah they could probably figure
that out but then you'd have to be
voluntarily done in a free country you
couldn't they wouldn't be able to get a
warrant to look at your phone
it almost seems like it's just a big
symbol to warn all these men yeah but
ultimately i doubt they can ever not
gonna stop me
it's like the gun arms right there
this is a gun-free zone
criminals are bringing guns into gun
free zones right
gun-free zone for sure so you think this
is not going to stop this epidemic no i
think it's a step in a good direction
that like shows a lot of you know
initiative it'll make some people think
twice i think it's something that some
politicians gonna feel like it helped
his election if he says he's for that
but i highly doubt you can slash it's
one step in the direction of
acknowledging that that's the new thing
right yeah that's so true it's like
cyber flashing if you would have said
that to a boomer they're like what the
[ __ ] right what about if you send a
picture of that big black dude with a
big giant dick
oh the guy on the side of the bed that
is art again everyone
everyone saw that dick especially
through the pandemic like crazy so if
you're gonna say big pics guys out there
just send that picture that was like the
modern day like when you hide this
my most recent one i got i still got
sent one it was like my friend was like
oh [ __ ] look at this crazy like
ukrainian bombing and then there's like
a building right and you just see a
mystical
right before it hits is the [ __ ]
black guy
dude i heard his family was like super
upset that it was going around
everywhere and they were trying to ask
people not to post his he took the
picture he passed away right yeah
oh
but he's the one that took the picture
but he's not even alive that's even
that's somewhat funny
but that's
yeah but his family who has to live
through that does kind of suck
well that's like beethoven and i got
more famous than after he passed away or
something it wasn't a dick pic of
beethoven
they appreciated him more after he says
he has a big smile in that picture he
looked happy he wanted that picture it's
not like oh no they got a sex tape of me
an intimate moment he was proud like he
was like he was confident yeah he was
like
if you're packing that dude i'd be
confident too i'd never wear pants you
know me neither but i would though i
would wear just really high basketball
shorts it's just it's always picks up
[Laughter]
just look like if it dangles out are you
gonna be like
that's your fault you saw it yeah
[Laughter]
i don't even feel it i love that we're
just talking about the psychology of
this dude's dick pic that everyone knows
yeah yeah
because that that basically means you
can't send that anymore
[Laughter]
oh that's not i don't like this law
anymore yeah
so far it's in the uk you know what i
mean america is the land of freedom of
dick pics you know you don't get a
shovel because i still i still like
getting like rick rolled by that picture
got to know your audience dude
these guys are so different when it
comes to unsolicited i think that guy's
bigger than the uk too you think he's
huge i think he's big in general yeah
he's worldwide he's mr worldwide there's
a british equivalent of that guy in the
uk who is it
one of the princes i don't know quite
ginger dude do you think do you think um
are women send an unsolicited genitalia
[ __ ] way i got sent most by uh a
woman no no no no not that
and she knows what i'm talking about
company chat too
not jk not that dick i'm just saying
like uh
in the same way that somebody might be
like actually perverted and doing cyber
flashing or or a trench coat flash right
it's usually like i don't know any women
that want to do that because i think uh
the appeal for most people to flash or
do something like that is probably like
a power thing isn't it yeah i think a
lot of guys actually it's a reaction
thing and i feel like if girls if that
was a girl's mindset she want to get a
reaction of a guy and she showed her
like
it almost feels like gynecological when
they do it yeah
kind of like a lot like they're asking
does everything look okay
like well
if a guy gets a [ __ ] pic right they're
not gonna go oh
yeah they're gonna go
women can't weaponize that the way men
can the women if that means yeah cause i
think guys and girls will both respond
the same way to an unsolid
unsolicited dick pic they'll look at it
yeah
i might smile a little bit and be like
what is this i'll do that oh my god you
sent this to me
this is it go in my mouth no that's
disgusting
i would wait till i get home and then do
i do that you put your phone in your
mouth it's definitely a weird [ __ ]
thing both ways do you know girls that
like dick pics
no he's like can you send me their
number
i know girls that like so no most girls
don't don't like dick pics most guys
don't like dick pics of like their
homies actual day exactly right do you
have any crazy military penis stories
military because you're not in the
military it is pretty open sometimes and
people some people are crazy sounds like
you do though no no no i'm just saying
like i'm sure he knows let us know quan
yeah you don't have any military penis
stories a lot of crazy what's your top
military penis story oh he's a guest i
just want to hear you give him something
to work on yeah i'll share it i'll share
if you share it
he has special operations penis stories
oh he's
he's got a tattoo of his homie on his
ass you know oh yeah that's right oh you
do he showed us his ass last time do you
have any penis stories nobody does no i
mean like like just like people are just
open so like we had a guy
at mos school he had like like a nine
inch dick and as when as soon as we
started taking showers and stuff he just
thought it would be funny if he starts
chasing after people trying to put his
dick in people's butt
so it's just everyone
that's pretty funny that's what shaq did
right out of nowhere it's just running
and he's just like this and everyone's
like oh what the [ __ ] and he just knows
it's big it's just [ __ ] it's like
nine inches flaccid
did you ask to hold it [ __ ] no is that
your thing is that what you wanna like
you knew a fireman's grip with it
you said shaq does that i think shaq did
that how did they know that and i think
there were interviews about it later on
sportscenter uh yeah the lakers were
talking about it from back in the day
what about you dude did you have any
crazy military
i'm trying to relate so i'm not alone
no i just know there's funny stories all
the time that's why i remember boot camp
uh my um
bunk bait was his name was bird
probably like a six foot eight black guy
that he was like a reformed uh gangster
went to be a a pastor and then he joined
the military but you know how they push
you in the shower when you're all butt
naked and until you get to get into a
corner yeah like dick to ass yeah his
dick definitely grazed my chin
he was like six eight like i'm like five
four like running into the shower
pushing the corners like oh
[ __ ] oh my god
did he look at you and lick his lips
i actually never told anybody after that
but you know i was like nothing happened
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] to be funny yeah to be funny
well he didn't even need to jump
probably he just [ __ ] just sat down
probably feels like the bottom bunk to
him i like the nonchalant stories like
you know where they push you in the
corner in the shower all but naked
together yeah that part's the one that
we know
do they do that and holds you guys down
for showering no but you play games and
stuff is it like uh
like about everyone get in the [ __ ]
what is the shower called the head or no
yeah yeah everyone get in the head right
now so everyone's like running in there
like full sprint and then turn on the
hot water right now so it's scalding hot
everyone turn on the cold water right
now that's extremely cold get the [ __ ]
outside right now now you're in the dirt
[ __ ] doing push-ups but naked go back
inside you're scrubbing each other right
now you're putting soap on each other
these games sound fun
is it co-ed right no no no no no
so like every in boot camp every time
you're supposed to do something
is a chance to [ __ ] with you you know
what i mean so like wow okay we're gonna
brush our teeth by the [ __ ] numbers
everyone squeeze [ __ ] toothpaste and
like get in this guy's oh this guy's not
putting up toothpaste and it's like
[ __ ] toothpaste now you got
toothpaste all up in your eyes brush
your [ __ ] teeth and you're like oh
i'm so [ __ ] sorry why the [ __ ] would
i join this [ __ ] damn is that still
something you want to do
but it's just not so i think
that's like you had me at naked
it's non-stop so it's like the minute
you wake up even when you pee so you
have like 60 seconds to pee and there's
90 people and maybe only 20 stressful
only like 20 urinals so you got people
you're like tripling up three people to
a urinal or you got a guy taking a [ __ ]
i really have to go and someone's just
peeing right right through because you
don't have time so you you learn to be
very efficient
that's pretty cool though
which is why you get really open i'm
like there's a ton i know there's a lot
of penis story right because after that
it's like you guys go through you're
like oh okay i understand like the like
the world construct that you have of
like what is comfort and whatever you're
like oh everything's comfort it's
actually pretty cool most things are
comfortable
dude
they mean the chin with it
[Music]
[Music]
you